As we've seen, in order for a cache to be effective
the hit rate must be high. That is, we need to
be able to anticipate what data the process will need next.
Ideally, we would be able to look ahead in the code and
plan ahead, but so far this has proved impractical. Instead ,we
used the heuristic of locality. That is ,we assume that if an
application accesses one memory address, then it will need nearby addresses
soon. Sort of like, how a psychologist says that the best predictor
of future behavior is past behavior. Experts like
to distinguish ,two types of locality. Temporal and spacial.
Temporal refers to the tendency to refer to the
same memory close and time. The spacial, refers to
the tendency to access memory that is close
together in terms of address. Typical cache policies exploit
both kinds. It exploits temporal locality by putting the
data in the cache right after you use it,
thinking that you're likely to use it again soon.
It exploits spatial by putting not just the memory
address that you access, but putting the whole block
into the cache. Blocks, I should explain, are a division
of memory by relatively small amounts, often 64 bytes.
This one block is from zero to 64. Another
from 64 to 128, etcetera. If we access the
memory location, 87. Then we reason that we are likely
to use addresses close to this one. And so ,we put
the whole block, from 64 to 128, in the cache. Now, you
may ask yourself, why do we put the block of memory into
the cache instead of something more consistent? Say, maybe, the previous 32
bytes, and the next 31 bytes, or something like that. After
all with blocks, sometimes most of the data we pull in will
be higher in the address space, and sometimes most of it will
be lower. Well the answer is that, it makes it much easier
to figure out what is in the cache and where. The size of the cache
block is always a power of two, so we can read which cache block we
belong to just by looking at the
higher-order bits. The lower-order bits are called the
offset And tell us where within a given cache block the data we want is.